hello everyone today we are going to see
how do we install python so simply type
python
on your browser and you will be
redirected to download the python from
its original page
now once you are here
the url is
python.org downloads just click on the
download python icon and the latest
version that is 3.10 would be downloaded
you need to wait for few seconds until
the download is complete
now that the python 3.10 version
download is completed
just double click on it to open the
installation box you need to check on
the add python 3.102 path
and also we are going to customize the
installation according to our needs so
just click on customize installation
here you can see that the
pip package would be installed as well
that includes all the python packages
and also the idli would be installed
just click on next
click on install for all users
and the other options shall remain
default
you can also change the
path or the location of your python in
the program files or maybe some other
drive that you would like to i'm not
going to change the path and
let it remain the same
now just click on install
and
wait till the installation is completed
now with this setup you have also
installed pip and idli
the pip installation would help you
manage the python packages and the idle
installation will help you run the
python programs easily
so now your setup is successful now
let's check it so just go to the command
prompt right
command or maybe cmg
and let's see what the version of python
is that we have recently installed just
to see if the python is successfully
installed or not
so just type
space dash dash version
we have successfully installed python
now let's try the idle shell
let's type in a python command to check
if it's working
let's write
comics
logic
learn
yes it works
you can also open up python directly
and check if that works for you
so let's write a very simple command
officially welcoming you to a
bioinformatics community thank you for
watching